hey everybody welcome back it's tuesday
june 15th
uh cliff and i are here today with our
guest david pakman
uh david is an argentine born which i
didn't even realize until i was looking
at this a minute ago
um american progressive political
commentator he is the host of the
youtube twitch talk radio program
the david pakman show and just to give
you a sense of
how well that show is doing i believe
david's got about a million or more
followers on youtube for his show so
david has really made an incredible
impact
um david is also again i'm like
forgetting my
david pakman history here but david is
an immigrant or one-time immigrant uh
his family he was born in argentina
buenos aires
immigrated here when he was a kid which
is why your english is so good because
i've my mom immigrated from greece at
eight
and her english is perfect but some
people still hear an accent but
otherwise
i don't and it's also flawless english
but does anybody ever hear an accent
with you or not
never okay because you were here at five
so you really were able to nail it
yeah but with your fluid spanish too i
am i am indeed
actually you and you spoke spanish at
home i'm guessing and you still nailed
the english
interesting just because with again the
greeks i can tell you
it's funny you'll meet greek americans
who basically have a little bit of a
greek accent and i've met them and gone
oh where were you born cincinnati i'm
like no no but like
and literally we actually have lots of
greeks here dude our chili is based on
your heritage john there you go chili
really
yeah it's greek the greeks who settled
here did their whole thing i'm telling
you chili greek chili
okay wouldn't be as hot anyway so david
thanks for joining us
uh pretty much you know our show is
always just the topics of the day
um you know going through your twitter
feed it's
you've been kind of on everything we've
been on but i'm curious first and i said
this before the show
just to ask people kind of what is your
political philosophy and let me just
tell you
i think um cliff and i and talking about
this
had a supposition that you were to the
left of us
um and now i'm kind of wondering from
reading your feed if you really are
what what are you i don't know i mean uh
you know clifford cliff and i have hung
out a little bit and
yeah we know each other from some of the
things i've heard him say
make me make me question that no i mean
i don't know i consider myself
basically uh in line with northern
european
social democracy in terms of economic uh
perspective
okay in terms of a lot of foreign policy
stuff
i i you know i mean to probably cut to
what
is right now kind of most prevalent in
in the
splits within the left that are taking
place i don't
play coy with any of the authoritarian
strong men
that some on the left are sort of toying
around with right now
you won't hear me defend putin you won't
hear me defend assad
who could you be talking about you won't
hear me
you won't hear me defend nicholas maduro
or
she or deny what's going on with the
uyghurs
you know i mean just i don't i don't get
involved in it can i say something along
those lines david i mean
no further i mean do we do we even
consider them on the left anymore i kind
of feel
when you get to the point where you're
defending authoritarians who committed
genocide for
lack of a better term i mean what's
going on with the uyghurs is
genocide what's what assad is doing i
mean i think there's a there's a bunch
of people that many of us thought were
on the left
and maybe they were at one time and
they've either changed due to
profit motive or belief or you know
whatever
i mean i don't know that's what i would
say you're legitimate
you're like you're really the left i
don't know that they are well
the reason that it makes total sense the
reason i hate
to just start saying you're not on the
left and you're not on the left is
people also do it
to me you get a toaster sorry yeah
people do it to me when i fail to say
for example the israeli-palestinian
conflict comes down
simply to israel is bad and
that's it right like i i don't that's
not my analysis and then people say
you're not really on the left then and
so
i don't want to participate in the same
type of gatekeeping
that i'm the victim of in a sense okay
and i want to be very clear though
like i don't believe in the gatekeeping
either i do think
that when you get to a point where
you're sort of supporting authoritarians
and what they're doing i will keep that
and i think we can disagree on
should the minimum wage be fifteen
dollars an hour or twenty dollars an
hour
you know should you know should should
we have fought back in the day
for marriage you know a gay marriage is
something
uh in the courts or should we have
fought it you know as something in
different states i think
there's difference in strategies i think
there's different should healthcare
we've had a battles over
should we absolutely is single-payer the
only answer or the fact that germany
and belgium and others have made
multi-payer with you know very much
regulation
environments work and those are debates
i'll have and i can't say when
somebody's like well you think any
system that gets people everybody health
care is okay
we have to ban all private health care
and to me i agree with you on that but
to me
but i really do start excluding people
from at least my thought
of you being anywhere towards
progressive if you can if you can sit
there and say america is awful but
vladimir putin man
that's a good guy but don't you both
feel like that
i will say this as much as and chris and
i click chris whatever your name is
cliff and i
john mike call me whatever you like i
would say i think you may be a little
more amiable about this and that's
probably a good thing because frankly
you've got a million youtube followers
and i've got ten thousand so
you know don't take my advice but cliff
and i think might be a little more
confrontational
on those battles on the left but i will
say
thankfully i think it is a very very
very small number
who are the crazy putin russia defenders
you know who
like like greenwald but i mean it's he's
such a small although he's got a lot of
followers
i i my concern with the left
again we get into discussions about the
squad you know i've got issues with omar
and some of the stuff she does and
people don't like when i bring it up
but that's my concern with the left is
whether we're going too far left or not
and among people who actually have
influence whereas i feel like the
greenwald crowd and what
don't name names fine but you know
you're defending russia
you're just i don't know what you are
you're kind of wacky fringe that i don't
even consider
a significant impact really yeah i mean
i think i agree with you
that it's not a huge well so here's how
i would say it
it's not a huge slice of my audience and
what can be deceptive
i was just talking actually to jank uger
about this what can be deceptive is
when i touch the stuff that goes against
the orthodoxy of that slice they become
very loud
and i start getting emails like i used
to follow you but now i have to stop
and i used to be a paid subscriber but
now i have to cancel
and a lot of that is not true so they
want me to
i think they are significant but they're
not a significant part of my audience
and i think that i i need to kind of
keep that perspective right they're out
there and i think
are in there's decent numbers you know i
think i would agree with that dave i
mean i obviously don't know your
audience but i think there's more
more of them as who are regular everyday
people not the sort of huge influencers
than than maybe john admitted there but
at the same time
yeah i mean you know clearly just from
what you just told us the kind of stuff
you're talking about because john and i
also have i what i would call nuanced
and i try to bring context to everything
we talk about
it's easy to demagogue about stuff it's
easy to say oh well this is all this way
that's the you know
but it's the same thing like israel and
palestine is one of those things too
where i try to bring context to that
argument
of where there's wrong on various sides
and you know and i get yelled at for it
and the same thing with some of the
other things we do so i appreciate that
that that
you're not just pandering to have as big
a subscription base as possible you're
saying it
how you feel it do you actually have a
sense of who your audience is and i say
this as
you know i've been doing well i've been
i've been i've had an audience i guess
since like the mid 90s in a sense
because i was doing a lot of email stuff
back then for organizations
you know um then i was blogging and that
became a big thing and now it's more of
this and twitter and everything else but
with each segment along the way i always
found it kind of difficult
to understand who my audience was and
part of it and it's it's it's two sides
of the same coin is what you're saying
too whereas
i'd get criticism first of all and i'd
be trying to figure out okay
is that my you know criticism always
makes you worried and you're like oh my
god is that my audience
or is that some fringe or nowadays
not even french is it not my audience or
nowadays is it fake
is it being ginned up you know is it a
for example
you know there's this and i've mentioned
it before and like that
ben guy at nbc got got on my case it was
like oh there's no such thing the one
who debunks all the
you know who follows the the extreme
right online and jacob
what's it ben you know what i mean he's
a reporter but you mean the reporter
like the nbc
he's the young msnbc guy who yeah yeah
yeah he got on my case because i noted
for example
these you know young again who knows
twitter
uh hammerin's always the rose often the
hammer and sickle
and gay lgbt like the rainbow flag in
their profile
and they're the ones who would swarm me
over stuff but it was always a swarm and
they were almost always from england
according to their profile
you know and you'd kind of sit there and
it would bug me but at the same time i'd
go
this is not have you ever had a feeling
that like now for example do you think
you know your youtube
do you know who watches you i mean i
think that
the the tougher thing about youtube is
that it's really easy to just like
snipe on by and very quickly leave a
bunch of comments that make it seem as
though you have a bigger presence than
you really do so i tend to go more by
um the emails that i get where if
someone really takes the time i mean
some of them are horrible and some of
them end up
you know forwarded to the fbi but for
the most part the email somebody who's
going out of their
way to find my email uh our you know our
contact form
on my website and send an email i feel
like that
is more thoughtful than just like
someone leaving 10 comments really
quickly on youtube without giving
much of a second thought and that might
be the first time they sort of ever
heard of me
right the people who call into my show
etc you know i think that the
relationship with like someone who
listens to my hour podcast
every day i'm gonna listen much more to
that person than to some random
person with a username that's all
numbers on youtube
so i i i think in that sense i do
have an understanding of who the
audience is and you know it's mostly
pretty progressive people primarily
between 25 and 55 who are
relatively well educated you know i
don't think there's a any big shock in
terms of who the audience is
right right yes it's like oh probably
often who you you'd see at a warren
rally or
or uh i mean i'm guessing not just
warren you could go to
to buda judge you know i wasn't trying
to sort of
pigeon you but yeah the kinds of like i
think you know mainstream left
right yeah and i mean listen i supported
bernie in the primaries and a lot of my
audiences bernie but i
i where some people got mad at me was
when i said listen guys bernie doesn't
have the votes
and biden on paper has a totally
respectable platform given what obama
was and given what the alternative is
and
i'm voting for biden like i i just was
very upfront with my audience
relatively early that angered a lot of
people so you weren't sort of going for
the jimmy dore thing
no oh my god no i'm sorry
i shouldn't even make those jokes i'll
get you in trouble well no but i'd say
you sound like a political realist which
i like because again
you know it's interesting your political
realist who doesn't approach this with
animus
is is the combination because i think
yeah cliff and i try to be realistic
look we've got our views
we tend to be you know cliff's new york
i'm greek chicago so like we both
are kind of out there with our views you
know we talk fast like i talk you know i
mean just we are what we are but
but it's and i would i just add quickly
john you know
moving to the midwest and living in
cincinnati now for a decade
there's a whole new sort of layer of
perspective that i actually didn't have
as an east coaster
so we all try to learn with life but i
also i i really don't want to
to catch up but i think it's important
to say what i like about this and what i
like about you david is that
i don't do that kind of gatekeeping
except for off to the extreme that i try
to say
a lot of us can be good people that are
liberal-minded you know progressive
minded whatever you want to say we may
disagree on some stuff but that doesn't
mean i have to demonize you
right i go after some people i do i go
after glenn i did today but i do it when
i think that they're
operating in bad faith right you know
what i mean and when you seem to come in
good faith and say hey i just disagree
with you on this well i think it's
medicare for medicare supposed to have
those conversations
right right we're supposed to have a
sorry cliff go ahead john you know you
go ahead
the the battle over medicare for all
during the primaries drove me nuts
because i was i was watching this and
i'm like you know i mean first of all
the the esoterica of it drives me crazy
i mean if it's your issue of course
you've got to get into the esoteric
details
but the idea that if you didn't accept
and i don't remember if it was elizabeth
warren versus bernie versus whomever
but if you didn't accept their exact
program and you wanted something
slightly different
you know you were a sellout and it's
just i don't know anyway let's get away
from that i guess to
it's anyway it's just something that
sort of bothers me and i worry
a little bit on our side whether that's
growing
a little bit of this infighting and i'm
even seeing it
for example i mean we i don't want none
of well actually maybe you can weigh in
you're latino
but i was reading yesterday you know lin
manuel miranda is in trouble again
apparently he was in trouble with uh
hamilton which i did not know
initially with some people because
slaveholders
he was honoring slaveholders and this
time this time is really interesting
the latinos in his new movie in the
heights which i'm told is really great
and it's on hbo and i'm going to watch
it
aren't dark enough he didn't include
black skin latinos and lead roles now i
know nothing about this
but as an outsider who watches it in my
own gay community lgbt community and
certainly seeing like the women's
community where
you know black feminists hate white
feminists and i mean it's just like
i i i'll throw this because we've both
been talking too much but i
worry sometimes that we're destroying
each other with our individuality
sometimes on the left
yeah sure i mean i don't i don't i can't
weigh in about
that particular thing i i'm not
following all of the cultural issues
super closely but i mean an example i'm
reminded of was
when there was this um situation where
the women's march leadership felt
that jewish women were not
intersectional enough to be on the
leadership because
jews are privileged and it's like guys
come on that's i can't
think of anything more toxic than that
that's like the epitome that's the
that's the
uh fork of three or four of the worst
instincts that are currently festering
on the left and i said at the time i
don't think this is the majority of the
left
right but i think that they are very
loud
similar to that slice of my audience
that gets very loud and starts to make
me think whoa is this really the vast
majority and the remember the vast
majority i never hear from actually
that's the truth because it's people
busy
living their lives but yeah i it's hard
for me to say it's a growing problem i
think it's a louder problem
um but that may be amplified by social
media and some of the other
things that are going on if the one
cricket in the field is louder than all
the sleeping cows
it's some adage i heard years ago and
i'm naming it a little but i love the
concept of
because it is it's frankly clifford and
social media only amplifies that as we
know
yes that's what i mean it's what we do
for a living to some degree cliff you
know i mean when on our
on our political side or our political
consulting side
is how do you amplify voices and
sometimes make them seem louder than
they are that's what the internet is
in many ways you know yeah but no
question yeah no question
now what i've got to look here and see
the you know you
can i ask you something how and some of
this i've i really wanted this
we're going to get into a lot of the
substance too but i i'm
just in personally curious about you as
david pakman sort of political guy
um i know cliff and maybe i mean cliff
you can even get into this with him but
i was curious sort of
you grew up or you were born into a
jewish family are you very jewish
because i know cliff you can sort of
explain what my question means on that
front
well i'm not i'm jewish i mean the
question isn't am i religious i'm not
no but you know certainly i i identify
uh culturally
um uh very much so but no i'm not i'm
not religious
at all i was just curious where you
exactly culturally and ethnically i was
curious kind of where you fit in because
like
cliff and i will talk a lot about these
issues and he'll always note the same
thing that
he's well i always i feel like i have to
note it and maybe that's
like i overdo it it's just i always feel
like when i speaking for
if i'm speaking for a jewish audience i
feel a little bit like a fraud
you know just because i haven't been in
a temple in a lot of years and
you know we don't i i mean my wife is is
presbyterian that's who i fell in love
with and if it had been
anyone you've been somebody jewish or
muslim not sure i would have married you
know so i mean
that's led even more so even though i
came from a very secular family even now
that much more mixed i mean we do
hanukkah for the kids just because
sure and christmas both and stuff like
that but there's no doubt that i i
sometimes
am hesitant to speak for jews because i
feel like
i know i almost feel like a poser well
for me it's not so much about
like speaking for jews but i think that
there's a lot of people
who may not understand that judaism
you're talking about an
ethno-religious group and it's different
than
say i i've i'm now catholic i'm now
baptist
no i'm now nothing right that that you
know
when you explain to people sometimes
they'll say you know i did my
my ancestry dna and it came back 100
jewish and they said how does it know
your religion and then i have to explain
well no
it doesn't it's funny i could you could
you
if you convert to judaism you are not
ethnically jewish and if you
work out you remain ethnically you know
you have to kind of explain this so
i think that that's why sometimes it's a
thing because it's a it's a bit of a
different you know ethno-religious
groups are different than just this is
my religion and a lot of people
understandably don't know that so the
point that you're he's making right now
folks if you don't know is that we're
still stuck with larry kudlow
even though he converted out he's still
ethnically one of us and it disturbs me
yeah he converted to catholicism but it
doesn't you know he still is uh we're
still stuck with them
sure sure i bring the comic relief to
the show a fair disclaimer
let me ask you one last question on that
topic just because i was telling cliff
before the show
i was thinking back to 2016 and i'm
assuming you're
on twitter and active in 2016. all the
neo-nazi alt-right trolls that we were
dealing with back then
and twitter was not dealing with and
really horrific stuff folks i mean we're
talking
uh i even received it god and i'm not
even jewish
uh people sending you not just pictures
of auschwitz but they would send there
was this one meme of a
cartoon drawn of an oven and they would
put your face in the oven and i mean
just horrific stuff and twitter wasn't
doing nearly enough and at the time
uh jonathan wiseman who probably was the
new york times bureau chief i'm thinking
at the time
uh talked about getting off twitter and
he may have actually gotten off twitter
but he also wrote an opinion piece in
the times
which was fascinating for their lead
political writer to do
you know they don't really write opinion
pieces talking about how
he never really felt jewish growing up
he's jewish but
literally it's his ethnicity that he
didn't give a lot of thought to
so i think even in that sense he wasn't
super jewish even ethnically and how
everything that happened to him on
twitter that year with the neo-nazis and
everything else and twitter ignoring him
for the first time in his life and i'm
paraphrasing a little here
he felt under attack and actually unsafe
for being a jew and it really but it
also opened his
eyes to that whole world because to a
degree and it's really worth googling
folks the article
i think he was i think the article the
premise is that he almost was thinking
that we were
you know in a post beyond a
post-anti-semitic world in the same way
that sometimes we think a post-gay world
where oh homophobia is done at least for
the gays in the 1990s we thought we
would post a lot of things that have all
come back yeah
well and i don't think um you know one
of the things about it
is and this is sometimes not super
popular to say in some
circles is that because of some of the
tropes and stereotypes about jews
in the u.s over the last 20 years as
successful and privileged
there's a lot of looking the other way
about this stuff
where a much higher threshold needs to
be met often before
some people will take it seriously and
it allows it to fester and
people you know terms of service on
platforms might
sort of not deal with it as seriously as
they should for a while etc
uh and it's sort of like a vicious
circle of the tropes themselves
make it so that it's taken less
seriously and as a result
it grows even more it's like a feedback
loop
and i think people don't get on some
level and this is what i can say like i
this is where it i do feel jewish is
when you see
you know there's that italian soccer
player for example
who who wrote something and because he's
higher profile was out there
you know he plays for the i think the
new york red bulls the the professional
soccer team in new york and he's got i
think he's jewish
and and you know background name and his
own and somebody a group of kids walked
up to him on the upper west side and
started
you know yelling things you know and i
at him you know anti-semitic comments
and i grew up in new york city
and you know to me almost that was
shocking because it's hard imagining
that happening
but like you start seeing these stories
from around the country and it's true
it's almost like
we get there's this you know because
some jews have been successful
economically or educationally
this sort of view of like your privilege
you don't have to worry about anything
and
i gotta tell you like you know i have
been in a few of those environments
before
and you feel threatened i mean you do
you feel like someone could hurt you
just because of who you are
and i sometimes think that's overlooked
and we're thrown in
as i like to say what i'm joking about
i'm like the great thing about being
you know light-skinned and jewish and
male and strangers everybody hates you
right there's a serious you know there's
a serious discord there's some really
good writing
about this about how uh
ashkenazi jews this doesn't apply to a
lot of sephardic and
and and you know mizrahim but uh
people tell people what those what that
means i know so these are basically just
different
slightly different ethnic ethnic groups
and you know so called
white white european jews tend to be
ashkenazi if your roots are in ukraine
and
if your intermediate roots so to speak
after being out of the middle east are
in in
eastern europe you tend to be my family
and i think from what david is saying
here his family too
exactly yeah um you are you know what's
called white passing
in most modern kind of western society
in that
you if you just walk by someone on the
street you can't
easily identify them as something other
than white
that plays a big role in the kind of
invisibility of anti-semitism
in some circles because it's very easy
to just say well
passing you on the street you look white
therefore there's really no conversation
to be had here but
part of it is what cliff's talking about
which is you can still
be in these situations where you realize
that you actually are being targeted
but nobody can tell that it applies to
you necessarily because of how you look
it's it's slightly better but it doesn't
necessarily make it not a problem
and i'd say actually in some ways you
end up hearing a lot more
you do because people don't have their
guard up exactly i don't know
the interesting thing when when john
brought up sort of aspects of
it reminding me of the united kingdom um
you know so i studied my
junior year um at a british school and
they're already i would say was a much
more active
far left in the united kingdom at that
point there was very pro-irish rights
and other you know these kinds of things
anti-colonialism in this and
very anti-israel but to the point of
well beyond it being an israel thing to
sharing sort of anti-jewish stereotypes
and you know i and i that that has grown
that part of things in the united states
and i've seen more of it since at least
my college campus that didn't really
exist um
and at this british school like i heard
awful awful things right they had no
idea that i was jewish again i
light skin blue eyes could pass as
whatever and and
you know and that led me to overhear
this stuff and that was one of the first
times in my life i really was like wow
and i experienced it and sort of heard
the dark underbelly that i wouldn't have
otherwise
you know have witnessed yeah i've told
the story before on my show but when i
was in high school i used to work at the
now defunct
electronics retailer circuit city and
i had a situation where there was a uh
there was a co-worker who came up to me
and casually just said
those customers i was dealing with they
they were just such
jews and i said uh what do you what do
you mean what does that mean
he said they were they were just they
wouldn't stop asking me for a deal now
part of me
goes right black and hispanic people
don't want deals they want to be
overcharged
but but when i said to him you know
that's a really inappropriate thing to
say did you even know that i was jewish
and his reaction was to say
sorry i shouldn't have said it in front
of you
there you go yeah it was a it was true
what i was saying i just should have had
yeah and it's like just a total
misunderstanding of what's even
happening in the world you know
yeah and by the way you should see my
latino
aunt from panama who's a greek immigrant
so you know latino ish right she's more
greek
who came to chicago and she was haggling
over some stuff in marshall fields in
front of my mom
and my mom was my mom's greek but she
was dying
the aunt is literally haggling with the
woman and the woman marshall fields
which was like you know marshall fields
i know and she was she was she wasn't
even latino she was greek so we've all
got a little of that in us but
yeah oh god um you know let's get to the
to sort of some of the the
political issues you had just tweeted
and i mean cleveland i've been talking
about it a lot but who hasn't been
um i don't know if you were joking if
you were serious about worrying about
august with trump claiming he's going to
get back in office in august and whether
there was going to be violence again
were you just sort of throwing it out
there
are you actually concerned about this no
i mean i i'm i'm not
so worried that i'm actually i am
planning to be away in august but it's
just coincidence
i'm not so worried that i'm planning to
be in a bunker or something like that
but i think
i i i'm not saying it's it's likely but
i do
think that there's a reasonable chance
that when again
nothing happens and trump's not
president on august 31st that because
there's a little bit more of a build up
to this one then they're like i think
march 4th was a date but there wasn't
really much of a build up to it
with the reports now from the new york
times washington post and
the national review about trump is
telling people this about reinstatement
and it is it is more of a thing and
you've got them you know mike pillow out
there doing
who knows whatever he's doing et cetera
but i think that there's a
there's a greater chance also it being
summer
maybe that will sort of add to it to
some degree i'm so i have some concern
about it
do you think that's the intent well i
wait cliff let me ask him this real
quick though what i mean
oh yeah go ahead i feel like if i were
trump
if i were on the right trying to gin
people up i would want them to keep
getting disappointed i would want to
keep doing what we did on january what
they did on january 6th
i would want to keep pulling the rug out
lucy pulling the football
not because they get pissed at me but
they think oh we got screwed again
right you're keeping the grievance
building we now we know
trump won after doing all the you know
the audits in pennsylvania what
pennsylvania they want one in arizona
they're doing they're still doing a fake
audit
you know with those audits now we know
he won and we were supposed to be
reinstated in august and now they're not
letting us happen
so it's another reason for a revolution
i just i i worry because i think it's
not only
a potential side effect of what they're
doing i think it's the
you know it's it's not the glitch it's
the you know whatever the expression is
it's a feature not a bug yeah yeah i
mean i think if
eventually what they're going to get to
is hey you know none of that stuff
worked so we really got to vote in 2022.
that would be like the best case most
optimistic version of this is like a
really well
you know not well crafted but it's a
forward-looking get out the vote that
that's the most benign explanation for
all of us i hesitate to think that
that's the explanation
though me too i mean again you keep them
you know purposely in grievance
i mean the operation is about selling
things after all right
it's much easier to sell to people that
are just out of their mind and angry and
you know
hey this will make you feel better
this'll i mean uh rick pearlstein
back in the day wrote a great article on
the merging of sort of
a lot of the far right and and the sort
of grift
you know culture out there the sort of
you know a great thing on mike huckabee
you know with the here's your biblical
cure to cancer if you're just you know
sending that kind of thing out to the
newsmax list um and so i always think of
it from the economic perspective
and trump is more almost transparent
about that than anybody else not on
purpose but you can tell like it's about
money right so i
think that it's going to be constant i
mean they've got nothing to lose doing
it
there's very little downside and you
know it's clear trump wants to be the
king maker for 2022
if he can start uh being the person
who's also kind of
giving up donations uh and saying i'll
support the correct republicans
and tell you which are the ones not to
be supported and if he can get
some wins in 2022 and if people like
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
etcetera get reelected if they run
for re-election you know i don't know if
they're all running but i assume they
are
it strengthens trump's case for 2024 if
that's something that he's interested in
and at minimum it's something to raise
money on from from gullible people
right trump is actually the overview
he's going after the pennsylvania folks
now too
he's trying to uh get the you know the
state officials who didn't support
i guess the fraud audit or whatever now
he's trying to uh
basically hurt them in the next election
but whatever what were you saying cliff
well i was interested in david's take
sort of as an analyst
you know we've talked a lot about like
if you could call it the the joe manchin
kirsten cinema problem
on the show here um again i try to leave
my anger and passion out of it because i
have moments of getting quite angry at
joe manchin
but i try to do this from a sort of
political perspective just do an
analysis of
they're different cases right i think
kirsten cinema is from a state where
they elected a progressive secretary of
state kelly's to the left of her the
other senator they elected
a few other members statewide joe biden
won the state
um it's moving in a left direction i
very much believe that if she doesn't
get a a
in my opinion if she doesn't get a get a
primary opponent and a good one we're
failing
joe manchin's a different story like
we're never going to get anything to the
left of him
we get rid of him who knows what we get
from west virginia and i feel like that
has to be
that has to be handled by biden schumer
or other people who can pressure him
from
the inside because i just don't think we
have the kind of power again it's not
about what i'm angry about makes me feel
good it's about getting
results i'm wondering if you think is
that a too facile an analysis from your
point of view
do you oh you've been that's basically
been my view
you know with the the idea of
immediately primary mansion
if you manage to defeat mansion with
bernie right or whatever
it's very likely that that seat goes to
a republican
and then you don't even have someone
that you can pressure whereas the
arizona situation
uh i think that you know the the mansion
one is more likely to be a pyrrhic
victory if there is to be a victory
whereas with with cinema i think
that she's really at risk especially
given the direction that arizona's been
going in
and you know as i've said before biden
has bragged for a long time about
he's the deal maker he's the negotiator
he's brought left and right together
republicans and democrats well just
convince this one democrat about a few
things you know like let's actually put
that
uh experience and and use that to get
this one guy to support some of the
relatively uncontroversial things you
want to do that are quite popular really
with the american people infrastructure
being at the top of the list
and in west virginia for that matter and
for west virginia which is a disaster on
infrastructure
right um that that's generally my view
and i think that
at whatever level of disaster joe
manchin is for democrats a republican
would be a bigger disaster yeah and i
agree like i mean there is pressure and
buying there but it's true this is
you know when people are unfair you know
and i always disclose i wrote some tv
ads for joe biden and so i've worked for
i don't work for him now
and and i think on some things i'd give
him credit i think he's done a great job
but i do think
on this it's very clear he ran on this
this is what he said he'd be able to do
and so it's true we can't pressure
mansion electorally the way we can
cinema so it really is it's on joe biden
to get it done
he said he could and this is going to be
a big test of of
whether he can or not because you move
you know again we're looking at at big
things here it's not just
over arguing around the edges here this
is about democracy it's pretty
straightforward as a bernie primary
supporter
how uh how good a job has joe biden done
well i think that the rollout of
vaccination has been
phenomenal essentially i mean you know
uh the best
understanding we have right now is that
he was handed essentially nothing from
the trump administration
and now basically vaccination in the u.s
is
is the envy of the world i know people
from argentina coming to miami to get
vaccinated now they're allowed to
foreign stimulus
he got it done within a few months i
know that there were some people who
who said well he said he would do it
right away and he didn't i mean i think
three months is reasonable for how the
federal government moves two and a half
three months i think that that was
really good
um there are certain things you know a
lot of progressives are furious with joe
biden on like he hasn't yet done
student loan debt forgiveness i never
believed he cared about that issue i
never thought he was going to do any
forgiveness so
i'm not let down in the sense that i i
just never thought that was really going
to be something he was going to pursue
right um there's he doesn't like the
issue either clearly i mean
yeah um you know his criticism that he
hasn't uh yet
done the public option on which i say
let's wait a little bit you know i think
it's
we've got to allow some time but i do
think that
by the by october 1st
there has to be some additional big
legislative accomplishment
to point to in order to start the 2022
period which will probably start in
january with like a case
that you should elect more democrats if
that's the case that he plans to make so
i think he needs infrastructure or
something else by october 1st
we had paul begala on and paul said he
thinks august is when it starts
the next election season so he felt he
felt by august we've got to sort of get
everything done we're going to get done
um that's that's even more aggressive
then yeah yeah well and and again maybe
you have more of a sense on
infrastructure i keep reading sort of
conflicting things one minute they're
stopping negotiating
next minute he's agreeing with them and
i would argue again
you know like i always felt like if you
can get a great a good bipartisan deal
uh get it right you said you're gonna
run on that
you know getting one quarter of what you
said you were going to do which is
what it's looking like that to me
doesn't feel like a good pipe in person
i totally agree with you yeah and and
again it's one of these things where
you're negotiating often when when the
negotiation is with republicans
and then none of them vote for it anyway
right so it's like
biden wants two points on covet stimulus
i don't remember if biden started at 1.9
or was it 2.1 or whatever
and then republicans say what about 600
million what about 700 million
it ends up being 1.9 they get zero votes
anyway so so what was
gained and my view is invite them to the
white house
so that you've done it you've allowed
them to be part of the conversation
do some kind of compromise even if it's
symbolic but then at a certain point if
if you're going to get zero votes then
just do it
with 50 votes this is now talking about
infrastructure right but you've got to
get joe manchin and cinnamon
if you're going to do that right and
that's where that's where it gets
difficult yeah
right right i don't think they are they
both is cinema not on board on
infrastructure right now i actually am
not sure right she may be
it may just be mentioned and it's not
right so really again yeah you got to
get him on board and
and i just there it may not be the
pressure of
you know electoral it may be more his
personal relationships you use to
leverage in west virginia
which he knows west virginia needs it uh
the the
republic democrat turned republican
governor there justice
right came out and said he wanted the
original infrastructure bill
yeah to the left of what manchin wants
because he gets that they their
infrastructure is awful i know when i go
from cincinnati here to washington dc
i decide not to fly and we drive through
west virginia i mean my god
you know i mean it's ridiculous and it's
needed so
i would think you might use some of
those voices back in west virginia
to prod him and be like dude
we need this right it's jobs it's
security it's whatever
so absolutely all right well and in the
end as you said there's really
i mean aoc for example kind of went off
the other day saying we shouldn't be
negotiating
mansion shouldn't be worried about
republicans we shouldn't be negotiating
with republicans but
that is the situation we're in with the
5050 senate and it's just it's something
that frustrates me a little well it
frustrates me a lot
politically because i want to get stuff
done but it frustrates me in terms of
sort of educating the grassroots because
they may not be up on politics as much
as we are
and i'm not even talking to people
watching the show because they are up on
it
but democrats in general or liberals or
progressives in general
probably do think biden's negotiating
too much with republicans and papa
but they don't realize even though
that's biden's way
he also has no choice because of the
mansion factor manchin said he wanted a
bipartisan bill or he wasn't going to do
it
and at least so far he's saying he's not
willing to do it by reconciliation
which means you don't have to worry
about which means getting around the
filibuster so for both ways mansion's
not willing
you got to get mansion or you know i
mean an aoc was out there publicly
criticizing mansion and i was like
no like you're doing an ad you're doing
a campaign ad for him
you know i mean that doesn't help him in
west virginia it is crazy
that for a lot of this stuff you either
need to convince 10 republican senators
which is
like how is that possibly going to
happen it's not or then
you're you're just trying to convince
your own party
it's a crazy situation it really is yeah
you know when you count seven or so and
one or two others voted for this january
6th
our you know jello spined senator who
thankfully is leaving rob portman
who didn't vote for impeachment but did
vote for january 6th
even if you add him in i think he may be
the only one who was on one you know
this
january 6 commission but not the other
one that's eight republicans
so your ceiling you start with really of
anybody
who's even slightly reasonable are eight
people right you're not getting 10 no
matter what you do
so you start off with you cannot defeat
a filibuster as
at its current level no matter what you
know what i mean and and
that's why it's ridiculous but but i do
think david again you know
john david did make a good point which
is like on some level
biden ran on on that he was going to be
able to bring people together he
so if manchin's the problem he's got to
get down to business at some point
and get mansion across the line on
infrastructure and some other things
it is on him to do that because i don't
know where else we're getting any
pressure on him from
right and in the aftermath you know if
biden runs for re-election
and his list of accomplishments is short
too short um having run on
i'm the long time deal maker and i can
negotiate with everybody and you
couldn't even get your own party on the
same page
it's not going to be a strong case for
re-election no it's not
so i mean at worst he's got to find a
way to you know to get people
win a couple new seats which is possible
in the senate in 22 i mean with
pennsylvania open and wisconsin with ron
johnson
off speaking russian or whatever he's
doing right now and uh
you know even here in ohio we've got tim
ryan and val demings getting in florida
but my bigger worry is of course
if they make it so that you can't win
electorally with
what they're doing in these states that
are gerrymandered
that's where it goes back to mansion
again yep
yep and i don't know i mean i don't know
how much you guys have talked about
hr one i'm not super optimistic uh
about that sadly i'm not hugely
mansion i mean obviously but why else
that's why or just a mansion you mean
well
if he whatever he will know he will not
support
yeah yeah i'm referring yeah that and i
mean i don't know maybe the support from
there may be other senate democrats
where the support is soft i don't know
but even so they need 60 because it's
voting yeah he went over to the
filibuster
yeah so he said that he you know lisa
murkowski has already agreed to vote for
it wonderful right so we have 51 votes
and maybe you know susan collins are
frown her way into voting for it and
we'll get 52 and there's maybe in any
normal world one or two others that are
even gettable did you see what i mean
what mcconnell did last night
what did you mean about the supreme
court or something else i may oh yeah
he said if if there's a if there's a
vacancy in 2024
he'll do everything he can to prevent
biden from filling it yeah and then
wait wait wait and then he got asked
what about 2023 the
like two years before the election and
he said we'll just have to wait and see
about that
right so he wouldn't even care i mean of
course
i i know of course but it just this is
why i feel again like we
we don't we don't take it to them the
way they take it to us
we just don't they would they wouldn't
even first of all
i will say this as much as i'm
sympathetic to the mansion problem
meaning
you know what do you do with the guy
they'd know what to do with the guy
they they cut the guy's balls off and
stick him down his throat i mean
metaphorically they'd find a way to deal
with mansion you know
what i've said before is um i i'm not
for quote stooping to their level
in certain ways which includes you know
lying in the way that they sometimes lie
or
criminality overthrowing democracy for
example yeah exactly right
but on certain things like hey here's
the way we could crowbar something
through and oh but maybe next time they
get a chance they'll hold it over our
heads
what does it matter look at what
mcconnell's now openly anyway he might
do
yeah in those areas i think it's just
whatever method whatever the method is
to do it you just do it right
right they stole a supreme court seat we
didn't steal several of theirs although
we didn't have a way of stealing it
so now that we're back they're stealing
more it's like of course
they will always do 10 times not even 10
times infinite times worse than we do
and it partly is because we're the good
guys and we had uh
was it doug yeah doug padgett who was on
the other day who's a progressive
evangelical pastor
who is trying to peel republican
religious voters off
uh using you know religious arguments
and some of what we discussed was one of
the concerns i always had about the
religious
left was basically their lefties and
they're not the lefties of the 1980s who
were fighting for revolution in
nicaragua
they're they're kumbaya lefties they're
nice religious people they're the
religion i was brought up
i mean like greek orthodox which it's
like catholic but without the anger
so like we didn't learn any of that
[ __ ] in church we didn't i mean we
just learned
love thy neighbor every sermon was about
loving thy neighbor
and it didn't deal with abortion or gays
or anything else right
and i think the religious left is very
loved by neighbor kumbayash which is
great
but it's not the fire and brimstone of
the religious right
and it it it it makes us i don't want
them to hate people like the religious
right but i do want them to fight
but there's an unequal in terms of the
fight well cliff we've talked about this
too where
fighting is concerned david fighting is
considered bad fighting is considered
republican
right no fighting has to be good and i
think i should mention you know
uh i i don't i really don't care about
the democratic party as a party like
i i've never been a democrat and it's
it's just a very practical
i don't i really don't care about
parties but i don't pretend to be
in i mean i'm basically exclusively
voting for democrats or there are
certain local races that are nonpartisan
like i'm not voting for
republicans i'm not playing the centrist
right but i don't really care about the
democratic party in the sense that
if i saw a better path if we fixed
campaign finance
and did away with it and did away with
first past the post and a whole bunch of
things were different
i i'd support whoever i thought was the
best messenger
and channel through which a progressive
socially democratic change
could could be made so i don't have you
know there's a bunch of different issues
on which republicans and democrats are
not significantly different and there's
a whole bunch of issues
on which they are very different and
right now i see most of the opportunity
coming through democrats but for people
in your audience who may not know me
i'm not even a democrat and i have no
affiliation with the democratic party
but it doesn't really matter no that
this guy doesn't make a difference no it
doesn't i mean i you know i
john i won't speak for john but i end up
you know i
pr and ad consultant it's for democrats
because democrats are the ones who are
closest to my
beliefs it's not because it's uh i
always will be a democrat and you know
i mean i mean if the democrats became
the party of southern democrats
i would not be you know back in the day
i mean so so i know what you're saying
right i have more of an affiliation than
you but in the end it's as a vehicle
yes and i think we use it
interchangeably i mean cliff and i use
the phrase democrat interchangeably with
liberal
because also what's the freaking phrase
are we liberals are we progressives now
aoc and company have taken over the word
progressive so like
but i'm not them like i'm not socialist
i'm just not
and and that's our social i don't even
think they're not i don't think they're
social democrats well this is the whole
other i mean i don't
even know that we want to open up this i
mean but what label do you think because
i think
there's such a misunderstanding among
many about what socialism even is i know
that's yeah but i think even but i think
even on the american le
here's something and again that always
drove me nuts and clifford i've talked
about this too
the fact that american socialists call
themselves
democratic socialists rather than social
democrats and my swedish friend had said
to me once
my swedish friend a friend of mine who
was very uh very
involved in swedish politics national
politics and he had said to me once he
asked me because why does
why do bernie and all these other guys
keep talking about you know being
democratic socialist he goes
those were the bad guys here like 30 40
years ago they were the craziest who
liked the soviets and stuff
social democrats are the are the ones
that you all
claim you like because you like the
northern european system
that's social democracy it's not
democratic socialist and even
it's a form of capitalism it's it's a
highly regulated
very regulated capitalism well but it's
also my point of wait cliff real quick
though my point is the phraseology
we go nuts because you'd rather use a
word with socialist in it than social
democrat
you're an idiot in america if your
messaging is democratic socialist
and not social democrat because
you've got two words people can handle
in one and you've got bad words in the
other
and it's just again we both do a lot of
marketing from a messaging perspective
which is you know when you're saying
stuff that people have only heard
from very authoritarian governments then
you're branding yourself in a way that
makes no sense to me
whereas social democracy i i think at
least if you follow stuff you
immediately think of scandinavia and
things that i
you know that i embrace perhaps you know
i mean that
i'm not a socialist i am a social
democrat i believe in capitalism but i
get to be
very much regulated i don't know which a
little bit yeah no that's my view
i mean even i don't have a problem uh i
don't i don't need
i'm fine with markets allocating
resources
in many areas but there are areas where
i think we
we need to uh say we need exceptions
here
and so when we talk about public
education when we talk about health care
i think there's an interesting case to
be made about basic access to housing
and food you know
that's a conversation where we say the
market may not give us what we need it
probably doesn't
but i don't need to either socialize
or even have the government involved in
directing resources when it comes to
you know the production of beach balls
or mobile phones or whatever the david
pac-man show right
sure yeah of course you know that's what
i always say is that
i i wish the government were a lot more
involved with especially with
larger businesses and we were breaking
up monopolies which are completely
skewing the marketplace
right so many horrible ways it's the
small businesses that i think should be
allowed to thrive
uh obviously i'm not saying there
shouldn't be regulations of course there
should be
um no discrimination and all sorts of
things um but i
i that's where i'm i'm not a socialist i
guess i'd say and i'm more of a social
democrat
um but i don't i think in the end david
you you and i
would probably not be as far off as you
think we would be no i don't think we'd
be that far off
yeah yeah you know and cliff i don't
know if you've got any other substantive
questions i've uh are actually
substantive but a political question i
wanted to maybe end with asking david
and i this may be too obvious of a
question that it's too hard to answer
um how what is the secret to your
success on youtube
do you even know or it just works here's
the thing it just worked i mean um
i think it's basically you're just so
compelling a personality
i'm having fun with you guys i think
that if if the
content is truly terrible there's no way
to to rescue it and to grow it but if
you meet a certain
minimum level of quality content which i
think i i mean i
don't think i'm the most compelling by
any means but what i think the
difference maker is
is consistency and sticking with it
right i've been doing this more than 10
years
and now we have almost 1.5 million
subscribers
right but after our first year i think
we had 7 000 youtube
subscribers and a lot of people would
give up at that point because you've
been doing youtube for 10 years
with your show yes yes indeed
okay so that's important a lot of people
would say you know okay i've got seven
thousand subscribers
if i just add seven thousand a year i'm
not getting anywhere but the point is
that's not how things scale that's not
how things
grow so the biggest bummer for me is a
lot of people come to me
and they you know ask me for advice
about what to do and the first thing i
say is
you're not even producing content
reliably yet you need to first figure
out
i'm doing x number of hours or videos
per week or whatever
and then do it for five years and see
where you are right right there's just a
lot of people that aren't that committed
to stuff and so
you know now that we're at the upper end
of the hockey stick and we're
hiring more people and and so on it's
all fun and games
but you have to be able to tolerate that
first part where
it's slow slow growth that's honestly 90
90 of it in my mind and you've been
doing a podcast today
sorry cliff but is your podcast do you
ever overlap them or is your podcast
totally separate from your youtube
it's the exact same thing so we do an
hour monday through friday
and then that gets chopped up and put on
youtube oh okay i got i thought maybe
you were doing a podcast too i was like
holy [ __ ] no okay
sorry cliff what were you saying no i
was gonna say the thing i've always been
while we've got david here i'll
embarrass him but you know what
i was always very impressed about and i
said this to you john when you told me
you're in a booking i'm like hey i know
david
um having met him at where certain
conferences trial lawyer stuff and some
other things is
is he adopted uh early which i think is
a huge thing with youtube when other
people are sort of like hey what's that
you sort of checked it out your research
did what you need to do and said this is
something we can grow
with but you also you professionalized
it early
and i would say you know that's the
second thing and third what you said you
stuck with it
a lot of people i know this because i do
pr so i'd have progressive clients with
books or you know
politicians or whatever i'd want to book
them someplace and i'd call up
you know half a dozen podcasts and a lot
of them would be like yeah i don't know
what's going on we may be doing one next
week or in a month and we may have some
guests
david i call up and he'd put me in touch
with his booker
because he had professionally realized
that he couldn't do it on his own
with what he was trying to concentrate
on had somebody doing the booking
scheduled it out you know and and had a
very consistent as
as you're saying you know i'm doing an
hour a day and frankly if you think
about how businesses are successful
that's how they're successful is you
create a brand you create
content where people know what they're
getting how much they're getting they
know when they're getting it
and you professionalize it in a way that
things aren't going to fall to the crack
so you deserve a lot of credit i don't
think
i think you're you're modest and that's
great you're a good guy
but you deserve credit and that you
didn't just like fall for like a turnip
and say hey what do you know we've got a
million subscribers like you put in the
work definitely
you turned it into an actual business
model or you professionalize it and you
just say
how much money can i grab immediately
you know and you're jewish too so i
would have thought you i'm just kidding
um yeah i know a lot of it is
systematizing stuff and saying
okay yeah like we have a bunch of
equipment sitting in a room
and we've got our team but let's
actually organize this into a flow
and a process and and really take it
seriously and that's ninety percent of
it
so cliff so i mean if you've done it
more you deserve it you know i was gonna
say cliff seven more years of the
podcast and we're gonna make it big
that's what i'm saying i mean all of
these things are
it's the typical s-curves you know and
and if you read about the growth of a
lot of businesses
it's there's this acceleration and then
there's a leveling and then what you do
during the leveling is what sets you up
for like this period we're in right now
i consider to be we're kind of
consolidating and building
infrastructure
so that when the 2022 election comes
we'll be even better positioned to grow
more quickly
you know let me ask you and i don't i
don't mean to turn this into a whole
master class but having said that
i it's interesting to me and i think
it'd be interesting to people
do if you're gonna get into this and i
think this probably applies to you know
tick-tock
anything else you get into as well doing
video or podcast audio as well although
podcasts a little different with
just audio but do you have to go as
professional as you have
you know you in essence have a studio
and i think
even for me that scared me to some
degree i mean cliff and i doing our
stuff right we've occasionally tape i
mean we taped this of course and i'll
put it up there
but i find when we put our tape stuff up
there it does okay
i mean our video unless it's mary cheney
by the way cliff mary cheney's the one
that people really like and
it's the one that youtube always limits
the ads on on mary's stuff
no you mean you mean marry trump don't
worry trump not marry cheney marry trump
sorry
yeah we didn't i haven't talked to mary
chaney yet she wouldn't come on no i
mean here's my
here's my view on that i always if if i
have the option
of doing something today that i would
call a seven out of ten
or spending the next four months and
starting in four months at a nine and a
half
out of ten i would rather start today at
a seven
and have four months of data four months
from now
uh i would always prefer that it's uh
the one the one thing i really learned
in in graduate school in business school
was the push cart method
which is don't spend a year signing a
lease for a huge restaurant before you
know whether anybody wants the food
just put a food cart out there next week
and
and and start building so you you really
only need i mean a blue yeti microphone
which is 130 bucks
and you know 160 dollar logitech brio
camera
and for 300 you can start putting stuff
up on youtube
and before you know it you might have
500 subscribers and then you build off
of that right
yeah you know that is interesting
because i will say although i think
the internet honestly god we really
could do a whole broadcast on this at
some point because i think it is really
interesting
the blogging in the 2000s right
which i had one of the big liberal blogs
and what was interesting about that was
it it changed as i was writing it
because i started seeing
it wasn't uh in a it wasn't in a bad way
it wasn't like i said hey what the hell
the money's here let's go that way
it was more seeing what people liked and
what they maybe weren't into
and all of a sudden i started blogging
about my orchids because people liked it
and
so all of a sudden it got a little more
personal and it was sort of it's it's
the same thing happened when i was at
children's defense fund i'd started
doing a lot of online uh advocacy for
them this was like the mid-90s when
things did not exist like that and you
know started sort of this email list of
theirs
that again morphed into something
different because people started writing
us back and saying you know
uh helen did a new child care bill
update could you send that out and i
thought
[ __ ] i already mentioned helen's bill in
the next update and all of a sudden they
wanted legislative updates so i started
doing it but you
you find and i don't but i will say
cliff i i don't think we've got enough
of a sense from our podcast
of that kind of feedback but sometimes
you can get the feedback that
shows you oh this direction you didn't
even think of
is the way this tool or this project is
now
trending yeah that's really that's it's
an ongoing um it's an ongoing iterative
it's a lie and and so a few years ago
i said let's just see what would happen
if i did a live stream and then now live
streaming is a totally separate business
that does really well for us
but there's five other things i tried
that went nowhere and so you abandoned
them when you when you identified that
that's the case
uh yeah it's you're constantly kind of
evaluating and judging that
which makes it fun if it works it's just
i think it could be frustrating because
it's
it's not always obvious and you're kind
of going
you know and you've got the problem too
of the people you hear from
are self-selecting in a way so like even
doing polls of our listeners or polls of
our audience
were we were trying to pull people to
find out if they wanted shorter or
longer podcasts
because our podcast tends to be and
we'll let you go because i know we
promised you an hour
you know we've done about an hour 15 now
that's our typical podcast length
i asked people and said would you rather
have us do 20 to 30 minutes
because cliff was advocating for that
three times a week kind of thing yeah
and of course our listeners went no
but i started telling cliff i was like
but is that because our listeners listen
to a podcast that's an hour and 15.
right well there's so one thing about
that is um
sometimes it's not that the audience
doesn't know what they want but to give
you an example
regularly when we ask people what types
of stories they want more coverage of
international and foreign policy is
always at the top interesting and
the stories do terribly whenever we do
that so
the people that are answering are not
the majority of the audience
yeah or or or they're giving you like i
said oh we think we should all eat
vegetables they're giving
you the answer they think they should be
giving you that could be right that
could be
no that's hilarious that is hilarious we
think ecuadorian literature
um from the 17th through the yeah i know
what you're saying
um oh the other thing i was going to say
about that is even the failures i think
are super valuable because and i
realized this when i was
just casually having conversations with
people over the last year with small
shows that want to grow and i would hear
them say
i'm thinking about doing this thing or
that thing things i had already tried
and failed at
and i realized i now have a list of
things that that
aren't likely to work and when i tell
someone else that that lets them skip
way ahead
in their development process and that's
super valuable too
that's great you're very slow on your
show and you're not as slow here what's
that about
is it i don't know i have no idea
i was telling cliff because i mean i've
watched your show before but i pulled up
something i don't know why this morning
and
i would say david pakman
talks a little like this whereas
john i would have given five times the
number of words in that discussion
and it's something that i've always
wondered about listen to npr i mean pr
is certainly
slower and more reasoned and it's
clearly not the way we talk
bob says a little more that way i would
argue maybe that when i'm laying out
ideas
just by myself yeah i'm thinking through
them as i do it whereas maybe because
this is more conversational it has a
different
cadence you don't know that that would
be my guess if it's you alone you're
right because if you're thinking alone
you might be
you might well you know john when you
think you're trying to lay out policy or
trying to lay out something like that
you
you're kind of stopping along the way
you want to make sure you kind of get it
right whereas now we're just kind of
going but it also makes me wonder about
what works i've always wondered whether
people want uh whether it's easier for
them to listen to somebody speaking
slowly i
tend to not i can't stand it i don't
mean yours
but generally speaking if i meet and
talking with you here you're not slow at
all but when i meet people who speak
slowly
i want to pull my hair out sure we've
all been to dinner
you're anticipating well you're
anticipating every word they're gonna
say and you're like
oh my god um but but it's made me wonder
whether for
doing online media if slow is good and
welcome because that
for whatever reason works better for
people for older people it does i know
my mom
you know my mom goes she's like slow
down stop it tell me again what you just
said
you know like you do get to that age
where we're all at least for that
demographic
you can't talk like me you know i mean
that's a given
yeah but uh mom would love you you're
like that david kid i understand him
[Laughter]
all right david we will let you go this
has been great thank you thanks so much
thank you for watching seriously yep
always great seeing you man thank you
guys okay good luck bye-bye bye-bye
chip remove david pakman
there we go right not gonna report now
wants us to report david pakman we're
not gonna report david pakman for
removing him
no no we don't need to do that he is so
interesting i'm glad we had him on i
mean i really uh
um i'm in tree cliff because i did
i did suspect he was going to be far to
the left of us and i would almost say
i don't even know what is first of all
if he is supporting european democracy
or social democracies
he probably is to the left of me i don't
have a problem with them but
but if you say that they would depend on
specific issues
because on a number of things from
education to health care whatever health
care i'm there
i believe
yeah i don't think he's as far to the
left of us as you would think no i think
he
is what i really like about him is again
it's it's really more stylish he's
reasonable you know
that's what i mean when you get to sort
of when it's angry
sort of populism of calling people out
and demagoguery
then it's divisive no matter what your
ideas are no matter how far the left
they are
and i admit like i get caught up in it
because i do
i don't do it with what i moved you i
moved you on the screen
i moved you on the screen because the
way my computer works if i'm looking at
you it has me looking the other way
so i moved you to the other side and of
course what did it do it had me looking
again the other way
i'm sorry no i'm just saying i i
try that that's the side i aspire to and
i admit when i feel like people
are nasty and show up in bad faith yeah
um then i still go after them and i i
want to tear them apart but
yeah i think are we better served when
we say
we disagree on stuff this is the new
year evil he's the pbs doesn't mean
you're bad
you're evil i'm you know whatever it
means we're going to disagree on some
things but like
we're all coming from similar places and
let's try to remember that but i love
that he's a bernie guy
who basically said you know what biden's
our best chance let's go for it
and that that is the epitome of
what i've already reached like person
politically because
that's what i but also he was a birdie
guy
right but but if bernie had been our
nominee i would have supported him yeah
you know like it's looking at something
you know reasonably and saying
this may not be exactly who i wanted but
it's better than the alternative and the
best way of getting what we want now is
this
and then but it's a very uh it's nobody
it does he any
and and we'll see i'm gonna see maybe
i'll even break this show up a little
bit because i think
it's it is interesting to me to hear him
god we could do a master class with him
on how to
you know i know some of you listening
may not care what makes his show work
but i think
i think god there'd be a big audience
out there that would love to hear david
pakman's tips for
what makes things work online because it
is very mystical i think to some degree
you know i think we found that ourselves
even twitter cliff right i mean twitter
i found twitter my twitter followers
increased a lot from uh
uh 2016 to 2000 excuse me
leading up to trump's election like that
year they quadrupled
so during the hillary trump fight and
then they stagnated and they've been
stagnated since then
and it's it's weird like hard to know
mine shoot it up sometimes then stop
then they you know it's i don't know you
know but it's it's i think it's gotten
more
i almost wonder whether it's gotten more
difficult to uh
understand the ebbs and flows on social
media what people are really thinking
what works you know it's a very anyway
it changes but i
know i agree i i think it takes a lot of
research and a lot of effort and it's
very hard to understand yeah
anyway he's really i like him i like oh
she worked closer by he's a lot of fun
yeah david pakman exactly
and that i don't think there's much i
think we covered it all i think we
covered it all
um all right guys uh today's tuesday i
don't think we've got a guest yet for
thursday
ah listen to you know what you do for
the week after but i'm not sure we do
first we've
got well we can tell people we've got
representative richie torres is coming
back next week yep he was awesome
very good um actually we can have that
conversation with him that uh would be
interesting when you're talking about in
the heights
he's afro excuse me you know i know if
he wants to get into it but i think
maybe he at least knows
what the discussion is between light and
dark skinned lipsticks because he jumped
into the israeli
palestinian conversation you know where
a lot of people would have hidden under
something so i think he's the type to
not shy away from talking about right
right kinds of things right we'll see
all right guys
uh we'll talk to you on tuesday
day-ish that's right yep talk to you
soon
bye take care guys